when i was with cgi uh
my professional skills were same as
other colleagues of mine
so i wanted to know the latest trends
and i knew that particular skill will
actually
impact my professional growth and i'll
be a person which will be different from
the entire crowd
i had been searching data science
for like six months i've done my
research and
i looked a lot of courses if you google
data science currently you will see a
lot of courses flooded
but one course particularly attracted me
and then i spoke uh to some consultants
over the call that was a simply learns
course with pj data science
and i just wanted a deep learning also
added to it so they agreed and they
added a deep learning course with the
data science course
and
that helped me basically to
choose simply learn as the platform
where i would pursue this particular
course
after i joined nasdaq i got a chance to
participate in a hackathon organized by
microsoft and to the theme on autism and
finally i ended up winning this and that
all because of the course that i did on
data science
as this case study was on data science
entirely so the learning part of the
course starts with our programming
language it moves to python and it moves
to machine learning and nlp
but the focus they have kept it on all
the algorithms and
making it you use python because that's
what the industry currently needs my
wife is currently working with cab
gemini as a manager
we both are currently doing work from
home and when i took this course there
was lockdown was there so my wife came
in there and she stepped up she took
care of all the everyday household shows
so that i can focus on my work and this
goes being online i was able to manage
it very well we have reached a point
where good is not good enough people are
constantly being rewarded for being out
of the box or being different that is
why i wanted to be in the niche category
and do something out of the box this is
where simply learn helped me
being different
remember to invest in your interest as
that will set you up for success